no contract no peace for the first time
in 15 years more than 11 000 movie and
television writers in Hollywood's
writer's Guild went on strike
this is absolutely an existential moment
for the writing profession we want to
ensure that working on the handmaid's
tale isn't the last good job that any of
us has the decision brought Productions
to a halt and dealt a blow to an
industry that's been rocked by the
pandemic and the new ways people watch
movies and television the industry is
saying we're still not sure where this
is going we're losing money on these
businesses this is not the time to be
trying to squeeze us as hundreds of
writers from Los Angeles to New York
took to the picket lines we sat down
with the writers and union members at
the center of the strike to understand
what led to this moment and what's next
[Music]
the strike has pitted The Writer's Guild
of America the wga against the alliance
of motion picture and television
producers the amptp which represents the
major Studios we came to the table with
all these issues and what we got back
really felt kind of like gaslighting
yalan Chang is a showrunner on the Hulu
series The handmaid's Tale But to be the
fruit she's also a member of the
writer's guilds negotiating committee
she was in the room when negotiations
with the studios came to a head the
companies came back refusing to engage
with us on our core existential issues
the amptp did not respond to requests
for comment about Chang's gaslighting
accusations but Studio Executives say
every effort was made to engage in
meaningful discussions and bargaining
many of the issues dividing the two
sides are tied to the ways streaming has
completely transformed the industry as
the studios move towards a streaming
model it was an arms race Justin
hellburn is a board member for the
writer's Guild as well as a showrunner
and writer for the ABC sitcom Abbott
Elementary I've been teaching here at
Abbott Elementary for a year now the
staff here is incredible everybody was
trying to amass the most amount of
content as many shows as they could
possibly kind of pump out to compete
with all the other streaming services
then suddenly the orders of shows became
much smaller the amount of weeks that
they were asking writers to work also
became much smaller in a network
television show like Abbott Elementary a
writer typically has enough work to
support themselves for an entire year
because we make 22 Episodes Abbott
Elementary our writers are able to to
make a good living and live in Los
Angeles we should not be the anomaly but
in the new world of streaming episode
orders have declined to 8 or 12. and
unlike network shows many stream shows
don't go into production until most of
the scripts are completely mapped out
there's this thing called many rooms
which have taken over Hollywood and it's
the studios deciding hey we're going to
put together a room of writers but
you're not producing the show you're
just like writing some scripts and
breaking out the season all of the
hardest stuff there is to do in writing
and because you're not producing we're
not going to pay you the producing fee
we're going to pay you the minimum which
is the least amount of money they can
legally pay us in response to the wga's
concerns the studios agreed to increase
minimum rates for writers working in
those types of development rooms still
writers say this new production model
has made screenwriting more like a gig
economy job between seasons one and two
we had a writer who had to drive an Uber
most shows you'll have a writer who gets
a 10-week gig or a 12-week gig and that
could be it for the whole year that
could be it for 18 months and a writer
simply can't live on that the studios
say that employment as a writer has
almost nothing in common with standard
gig jobs the studios would argue that
this is not a gig economy for starters
the pension and health benefits are a
lot better and secondly you're employed
on a weekly episodic basis and you're
getting paid every week a set wage the
studios are also confronting a rapidly
changing business subscriber growth for
many of the streaming companies has
slowed and viewership has declined for
network and cable shows they're always
looking for places where they can trim
costs whether it's reducing Staffing
within their own companies or finding
ways to squeeze every penny out of a
production budget the last time the
Writers Guild of America went on strike
against the Hollywood Studios was in
November 2007. it lasted for a hundred
days
[Music]
the strike centered on the way DVD sales
and video on demand were quickly
replacing rerun syndication as a main
source of Revenue the writers wanted
their fair share of those profits we
want our fair share we're here because
we care the 0708 strike was incredibly
successful because we won coverage of
the internet so for all the shows that
are streaming now it wouldn't be covered
by our Union if we had not strung in the
moments before the recent negotiations
reached a standstill the writers say
they weren't the ones to end the talks
it was the studios who came back and
said if you don't give up on
these countless proposals that are
essential in court to your negotiation
then there's no point in talking anymore
so they were the ones who walked away
not us we were there we were there we
had pizza we were waiting the studios
say that they listened to the wga's
proposals and presented the writers with
a comprehensive offer the student s have
spurred enormously from our shows the
budget for writing for each show has
stagnated while show budgets have
ballooned the wga says nearly half of
Guild writers working in television are
being paid minimum rates to address
these concerns the studios say they
offered a substantial wage increase and
created a higher floor for mid-level
writers compensation but the increases
didn't meet the wga's demands the WJ is
trying to put protections into our
contract for Riders so that we can get a
guaranteed number of weeks of pay at a
minimum that allows us to live and work
in Los Angeles the amptp said in a
statement that its offer included
generous increases in compensation for
writers and that it was willing to keep
negotiating the Studios have offered
increases in you know starting wages for
writers they would tell you we've
offered our most significant wage
increase in you know like 25 years and
then there's the issue of residuals
which are like royalty payments for
screenwriters writers are typically paid
less in residuals for stream shows
compared to those on broadcast TV the
streamers have been very protective of
their data so we have no idea how well
shows are doing we have to take their
word for it we would like some sort of
compensation that's tied to the success
of the show The amptp has provided some
counter offers but they did not meet the
wga's demands the studio streamers and
networks they have offered raises on
residuals and on uh minimum wages late
night shows were the first to feel the
Ripple effects of the strike with most
heading into reruns I also feel very
strongly that what the writers are
asking for is not unreasonable some
content providers are in a better
position than others to weather the
strike streaming services like Netflix
and HBO Max all tend to make their shows
far in advance but the fall TV season
for broadcast networks could be delayed
the writers room for season 3 of Abbott
was supposed to start
um May 2nd and we struck and so we are
not able to start our writer's room and
get to work on the handmaid's tale we
were breaking and writing our final
season when the strike hit we just all
closed down the room it was
heartbreaking
as the standoff continues writers
throughout the industry continue to take
to the picket lines none of us wanted
this strike but we are fighting we want
to be riding out at elementary we all
want to be making television shows we
just want to be paid fairly by the
studios for doing it
foreign
[Music]